des régionales mais tout de suite place
à bertrand et à son invité merci
christine effectivement et 17h14 aussi
en martinique première juste avant de
retrouver bertrand caruge et philippe
roques sont invités ce matin on retrouve
l'édito de jean-marc partie on y part ce
matin du duel fillon juppé les électeurs
de martinique auront à trancher eux
aussi entre les deux candidats en lice
pour l'investiture de la droite et du
centre à l'élection présidentielle c'est
le thème de ben moody ou ça ce matin
proche de cette droite traditionaliste
provincial tranquillement conservatrice
sur les questions de société et libéral
sur le plan économique êtes vous
rencontrés en plus tôt concernés par
cette droite moderne ouverte sur le
monde tolérante libérale elle aussi sur
le plan économique
choix cornélien entre deux visions de
filiation deux hommes de style si
proches sur leur projet économique est
assez éloigné sur les sujets concernant
la famille les mènerait droit des femmes
l'islam l'immigration le rôle de l'état
alors droite dure au droite modérée
qu'un préféré pour se décider les
électeurs de martinique pour réexaminer
le volet outre-mer des deux prétendants
afin de faire le bon choix le projet de
françois fillon n'est guère en profond
dit comme si sa réflexion sur nos
territoires n'est pas abouti celui
d'alain juppé en revanche fourmillent
des mesures concrètes comme s'il tenait
nos pays pour des terres d'avenir pour
la france ceci dit les divergences entre
les deux projets sont bien mais ce les
mêmes solutions étant proposés par les
deux anciens premiers ministres pour
juguler le chômage relancer la
production soutenir les entreprises ou
former la jeunesse le choix qu'on le
voie sera vraiment compliqué pour
certains ils n'auront qu'à se dire
qu'ils ne lisent pas un président pour
la martinique puisque nous en avons déjà
un il même pour l'outre-mer mais bien un
président pour la france pour qu'elle
france là est la question
[Musique]
c'était l'édito de jean-marc parti à
retrouver demain à 7h15 et en podcast
sur le web la première point france tv
info.fr
matin première 6h 8h30 c'est jim sur
martinique 1ère 1 1re 6h 8h30 c'est
jimmy sur martinique première mardi 22
novembre écoutez matin première et vous
avez raison bon courage à vous pour
cette nouvelle journée qui démarre
ombelles vont joue pour les céline et
les célia bon matin s'est faite à zot il
est 7 heures 16 bertrand carouge est
avec nous ce matin il reçoit le nouveau
président de la cci m philippe jacq dans
son caddie et c'est donc quelques
secondes
[Musique]
vous êtes chef d'entreprise implanté en
martinique vous fourmiller d'idées
innovantes
edf et la jeune chambre économique de
martinique vous accompagne dans votre
projet participez au concours martinique
territoire d'innovation dans une des
quatre catégories habitat connectés
ville bas carbone gestion des déchets et
e-santé déposer votre candidature avant
le vendredi 16 décembre sur le site
martinique territoire d'innovation
points comme
l'énergie est notre avenir économisons
là j'aimerais bien changer de voiture
mais c'est comme moi je les financer
grâce au prêt tout projet du crédit
mutuel oui mais l'auto quoi le tout
crédit c'est comme d'habitude avec le
crédit mutuel très avantageux avec en
plus leurs conseils et leurs solutions
pour mieux gérer mon quotidien manqué
hockey ou est en agence l' offre de
crédit valable du 14 novembre 2016 au 31
décembre 2016 réservé aux particuliers
sous réserve d'acceptation de votre
dossier par votre caisse de crédit
mutuel voir conditions complémentaires
en agence crédit mutuel une bande qui
appartient à ses clients ça change tout
écoutons rabbin de blois qui nous
racontent comment ils arrivent à gagner
30% sur chaque quinté + c'est sûr
qu'avec 30 % rembourser sur mes quinté
plus grâce à ma carte pmu j'ai visé
juste un oui robin en plein dans le
mille du 21 au 25 novembre pour tous
quinté plus de 20 euros minimum jouer
pmu vous rembourse 30 % de votre pari
grâce à la carte pmu
voir conditions dans les points de vente
participants jouer comporte des risques
appelez le 09 74 75 13 13 appel non
surtaxé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
martinique 1ère 7h18 vous écoutez
martinique 1ère philippe jo qui
l'invitait de bertrand caruge dans son
caddie
[Musique]
bonjour à tous merci à jimmy damas pour
cette introduction au philippe josse
bonjour bonjour votre à carouge bonjour
aux auditeurs de matières premières
merci d'avoir accepté de répondre à nos
questions vous qui est le tout nouveau
président de la chambre de commerce et
d'industrie de la martinique vous avez
été installé hier
rappelez nous pourquoi vous êtes vous
présenter à cette présidence de la cci m
philippe jacq déjà l'installation avec
le vendredi et non payet oui non c'était
le lancement de la semaine école
entreprise j'ai fait une petite
confusion effectivement vous avez été
installée vendredi média vous avez lancé
par le préfet de région école entreprise
on y reviendra alors alors installé
vendredi mais pourquoi pourquoi avoir
choisit donc de vous présenter à cette
présidence de la chambre de commerce et
d'industrie alors nous avions choisi
l'ensemble des organisations patronales
de martinique d'avoir une liste unique
et il a fallu trouver une tête de liste
et quelqu'un pour pour tirer cette liste
vers le succès et il y à une unanimité
sur mon nom de fait j'ai donc accepté de
remplir cette mission parce que je suis
depuis toujours au service du
développement de mon territoire
développement de la martinique et que ça
ce que ceux inscrits vers dans le
prolongement de mes activités de
l'activité sociale et sociétale depuis
quelques années alors c'est une
institution évidemment la chambre de
commerce comme dans d'autres territoires
français ce que je veux dire c'est que
cette institution est ce que vous la
connaissiez déjà ce que vous la
découvrirez ce que vous étiez déjà dans
le bureau est ce que voilà vous l'avez
déjà côtoyé vous êtes familier avec la
ccm je n'étais pas au bureau de la
chambre de commerce monsieur n'est pas
une obligation non
réglementaire ou législative d'être déjà
membre du bureau c'est une institution
que je connais pour la pratique et en
tant que professionnel puisque vous
n'ignorez pas que ces experts comptables
et que les experts comptables ont
l'occasion de travailler avec le centre
de formalités des entreprises notamment
et donc c'est une institution que je
connais dont je connais les
les services l'offre de service où je
connais l'émission est donc ce n'est pas
une ce n'est pas une découverte de
deux néophytes des rouages voilà vous
n'êtes pas un néophyte total donc même
si vous n'étiez pas dans le bureau
précédent alors
sans faire exprès j'ai fait un peu cette
confusion entre votre actualité d'hier
en tant que président du medef mais
sortant est sur le point de démissionner
ça doit se passer ce soir c'est bien ça
vous allait fermer onze allait
démissionner ce soir de la présidence du
medef martinique oui vous les quelques
mots là-dessus en effet j'avais indiqué
dès le début de la campagne que je
mettrais un terme aux fonctions medef
martinique mais aussi au medef national
puisque j'étais membre du conseil
exécutif ou où je représente l ensemble
des titres homair j'étais président du
club outre-mer du medef national et donc
j'arrête ce soir ses fonctions à la fois
au niveau local et au niveau national
pour me consacrer à la chambre de
commerce à côté de mes activités
professionnelles qui reste l'essentiel
il s'agit de alors précisément mission
bénévole c'est précisément philippe jacq
avant d'y venir c'est pour ça que je
parlais de votre démission ce soir de la
présidence du medef martinique je crois
que votre successeur sera élu dans la
foulée normalement voilà ce que c'est en
dirigeant les en grèce 2-0 et le conseil
d'administration qui va causer des
sensations résident là voilà ce que le
mandat le mans via les conseils valent
jusqu'à juin 2007 on verra a dit que
c'est bernard edwards qui pourrait vous
succéder on verra on le sait bien il ya
un vote ce soir donc on verra bernard
edwards directeur financier du groupe
parfaite voilà mais il vous reste la
présidence de ladom lagence de
l'outre-mer et puis également votre
cabinet d'expertise-comptable que vous
continuez à sap a fermé vous vous n'en
avez aussi alors comment vous allez
faire entre résidents cci m présidence à
domme et votre activité professionnelle
d'expert comptable je veux être clair là
d'hommes il la présidence n'est pas
exécutive vous avez aladom un directeur
général de secrétaire général sur de nos
collaborateurs
n'avons pas en talent qualité président
je n'ai pas de responsabilité au niveau
du dérèglement du suivi de la du budget
le conseil d'administration définit la
politique sur la formation sur la
mobilité et la direction générale mme
ernotte cette politique donc c'est
vraiment une mission essentiellement
politique ou avec le grand p au sens où
nous avons souhaité donné qu'il faut pas
négliger narrant 17 mai 7 je vous répète
c'est une mission non exécutive
politique le conseil d'administration
définit la politique notamment en
matière de formation professionnelle
l'idée aujourd'hui c'est bien d'avoir
des formations qui correspondent aux
besoins actuels et futurs les
territoires avec une logique de mobilité
à l'est mais aussi mobilité retour donc
le président de l'organisation que je
suis participent quatre conseils
d'administration et en lien permanent
par par mail et par liaison téléphonique
avec la direction générale mais ce n'est
pas que je répète une mission
opérationnelle qui me prend beaucoup de
temps comme le cabinet comptable c'est
c'est mon activité professionnelle que
je ne négligerai pas tout comme je la
négliger pas les peaux rouges des prix 0
du medef martinique donc il ya de
l'organisation il ya une équipe d'une
trentaine de collaborateurs et les
choses se mettent en place un planning
serré à mettre en place et j'ai toujours
j'ai toujours travaillé entre 12 et 15
heures par jour donc ça changera pas
beaucoup
alors certains dans les milieux
politiques et économiques à la fois
s'inquiète de liens que vous avez avec
le groupe monplaisir on dit que vous
êtes l'un des cabinets ou peut-être le
principal cabinet
expert comptable auprès du groupe
monplaisir dont un des uns des
dirigeants évidemment faut-il le
rappeler est conseiller territorial
premier vice président de l'assemblée de
martinique alors je répondrais assez
clairement à 7 à 7
louis réflexion d'abord il ya quatre ou
cinq que expert comptable et commissaire
aux comptes qui sont prises dans nos
chambres de commerce il n'y a aucune
incompatibilité de droit s'agissant du
groupement plaisir j'en suis un des
commissaires aux comptes le commissaire
aux comptes ne s'immisce faire dans la
gestion donc je ne suis pas le conseil
du groupe monplaisir mais son
commissaire aux comptes pour partie pour
une partie des activités nous est chargé
en validant les activités
environnementales d'accord mais
peut-être faudrait-il m'inviter sur la
mission d'un commissaire aux comptes et
les rôle de commissaire aux comptes pour
que toute ambiguïté sur le effectivement
c'est pas l'objet ce matin non
simplement fallait quand même vous
interrogé là-dessus demande est ce que
il n'ya pas une éventualité de s'en
aller jusqu'au conflit d'intérêts mais
d'une forme de logo de proximité un peu
bon voilà je crois que les gens les gens
se font une montagne de ces choses à la
réunion le président de la chambre de
commerce est aussi vice président du
conseil régional il ya t'il
incompatibilité il y at il un risque de
conflit d'intérêt je ne crois pas
les gens qui sont à la chambre de
commerce et les élus chambres de
commerce ont à l'intérêt de
développement économique ils auront à
travailler avec la collectivité qui
allait en charge le développement
économique mais je ne vois pas en quoi
mes responsabilités professionnelles
pour influer sur le le positionnement ou
de la ctm ou de la chambre de commerce
et d'industrie de la martinique
philippe jacq vous avez déjà visité
week-end dernier à peine installé donc
vendredi le chantier du nouveau paul
à ravine tous à la chaîne cher du
nouveau paul et surtout centre de
formation de la cci n quelle est votre
impression et est-ce une manière quelque
part de vous inscrire de vous mettre
dans les pas de votre prédécesseur aussi
qui a lancé ce chantier manuel beaudoin
non mais l'état il était important que
je visite de ce chantier parce qu'il a
c'est un chantier emblématique pour la
précédente mandature et qui a aussi des
impacts budgétaires puisque l'ensemble
des services de formation de la chambre
doit y être installés
prochainement et que si on les déménage
à paul consulaire on évite les loyers
qu'on paie actuellement et donc il
fallait que je m'assure de la date à
laquelle ce transfert pouvait pouvait
s'effectuer j'ai visité un très beau
bâtiment avec une conception vraiment
qu'elle était sécurité environnement
appréciable mais c'est vrai qu'il ya
quelques retards et que je pense que le
chantier ne sera pas les raisons de ce
forum aura comme le solaire a
entendu alors on y vient c'est votre
c'était votre dernière action en tant
que président du medef martinique en
tout cas dans la mandature là que vous
exerciez vous avez lancé avec la
rectrice d'académie la semaine de
l'école à l'entreprise école entreprise
semaine école entreprise voilà donc il
s'agit de dans votre esprit et dans
l'esprit de l'académie de donner aux
jeunes une idée plus claire de
l'entreprise et le thème sévères au
monde connecté cette année 1 alors
nouveau secteur en plein boom l'internet
des objets des dizaines de milliards
d'objets seront connectés les
entreprises commencent à optimiser leur
activité maintenance consommation
d'énergie etc en dotant les unités de
production de capacité qui rendre
visible l'invisible
au-delà de cette description est ce que
cette évolution cette métamorphose c'est
vrai qu'il faut bien sûr
la présenter aux jeunes c'est eux les
travailleurs de demain les cadres mais
mais ça correspond aussi à des des
pertes d'emplois des disparitions de
métier aussi est-ce qu'il faut pas s'en
préoccuper aussi ce sera aussi votre
rôle de chambre de la commerce de jeu
excusez-moi de président sur deux
commères d'accompagner justement ces
évolutions au sein des entreprises des
commerces
très clairement la semaine école
entreprise est une manifestation
nationale
organisée par le medef et le message du
coach national depuis le 2nd années
qu'on a décliné à la vente unique depuis
treize ans environ et chaque année nous
avons un thème qui permet aux jeunes de
se connecter avec l'entreprise hélas
cette année le thème porte sur les
objets connectés c'est à des métiers
vont disparaître mais d'autres métiers
vont se créer il était pourtant que
notre jeunesse martiniquaise soit au
fait de métier à venir des métiers en
tension aujourd'hui mais aussi des
métiers qu'il faut qu'il faut il faut
envisager plus tard pour que les offres
de formation qu'elle émane de la chambre
de commerce et d'industrie ou qu'elles
émanent de l'éducation nationale que les
offres de formation soit adaptée à cette
évolution à cette évolution du monde
très bien ouais pour pour les jeunes qui
vont arriver sur le marché du travail
d'accord bout qu'ils soient bien formés
etc mais ce qu'ils sont c'était un peu
le sens de ma question au-delà de ça
voilà il ya des jeunes aussi d'ailleurs
mais une décote est un peu moins mais
les additions qu'une des missions
essentielles de la force de la chambre
de commerce et la formation c'est la
formation tout au long de la vie et donc
il nous appartient la chambre de
commerce de mettre en place des
formations qui correspondent aux besoins
actuels mais aussi vos un futur les
entreprises
je profite de l'antenne pour rappeler
qu'à côté de ce module formation il y à
l'accompagnement les entreprises qui est
un des volets les plus essentiels et
l'offre de services vachon vocaux baisse
doit être mise à disposition d'ailleurs
ça va être votre dossier priorité à mes
quelques mots met à disposition des
ressortissants de la chambre et je
profite de l'antenne pour les remercier
de leur mobilisation sera plus
accessible plus plus lisible c6 est
désormais visible et je profite de
l'antenne pour les remercier la
mobilisation puisque avec 37 % de
participation la liste que je conduis
est une des mieux élu de france dont le
sélection de chambres de commerce et
d'industrie ah bah c'est là dessus que
nous allons nous séparer merci philippe
jacques président de la ccm donc qui
était l'invité de 5 à 10 c'était son
caddie avec bertron caruge donc quatre
minutes la chanteuse janis y rejoint
dans matin première elle cartonne avec
le remix de j'ai déconné elle sera l'une
des invités du téléthon des pompiers
samedi au grand carbet du parc aimé
césaire très bonne journée à vous merci
nous rejoindre bonne route et surtout
soyez prudents on fera un point météo
tout à l'heure vous avez vu il pleut un
petit peu ce matin et la chaussée et
trompait soyez donc prudents et bien
évidemment rester à l'écouté de
martinique 1ère et desservent 7h30 voici
le flash de france info
[Musique]
retour d'armand perron lauga pour l'info
de plus en plus de français ont du mal à
payer leurs factures de gaz et
d'électricité c'est ce que souligne un
rapport publié ce matin un rapport de
l'observatoire national de la précarité
énergétique
près de 6 millions de ménages étaient
concernés en 2013 alors qu'ils n'étaient
que 5,1 millions deux ans auparavant
cette hausse s'explique notamment par
l'augmentation des prix sarah lemoine
l'équation est simple lorsque le prix de
l'énergie augmentent de 10% cela peut
faire basculer 500 mille ménages en
situation de précarité énergétique or
entre 2011 et 2013 les tarifs du gaz et
l'électricité ont progressé premiers
touchés les ménages à faibles revenus
ceux qui gagnent moins de 13000 euros
par an il s'agit